et ben voilà on se retrouve pour
continuer notre découverte de la
bourdonnais est donc bon je pense mais
assez vu deux parties de son match
contre mcdonnell et maintenant vous
montrer une partie des contrôleurs
flégeau y tue ta paris en 1836 donc deux
ans après après son match est donc là
les pièces noires 4,5 et on va voir un
grand miroir donc était très à la mode à
l'époque
si on prend effet quatre cavaliers f3 et
donc le coût g5 qui est assez populaire
finalement donc g5 sarah quoi ça bien
défendre le pion et fiable et parfois
aussi à jouer g4 pour chasser ce
cavalier f3 et pouvoir poursuivre avec
d'un match 4 voilà donc après pour les
joueurs qu'il faudrait un jeu un peu
moins
je suis à conduire un fou quoi elles des
pions qui avance de partout je peux vous
recontacte comme des 5 par exemple et
sur qui on prend cavalli et 6 pour
vouloir reprendre soutien ensuite et au
moins et noir se développent et voilà
c'est intéressant comme ligne mais on va
regarder ce qui se passe dans la partie
donc j'ai 5 pouces et 4 e par les blancs
donc ils laissent faire j'ai quatre et
dessus cavaliers au sein qui a été jouée
par les blancs donc qui attaquent le
pion au 7 mai à noter qu'ici les blancs
l'option de jouer le violent dans be
with you c'est petit rock et sur qui on
prend x3 d'emprunt f3 donc il est blanc
simplement si vous avez tapé à fond sur
la recette on voit qu'ils ont vu le flou
ils vont la dame la tour ils veulent
prendre f4 et je vais à fond sous la
pression là-dessus et sur un coup comme
dan f6 évidemment les noirs seraient
ravis de pouvoir a changé d'âme les
blancs font le 52.5 sacrifice en 7.97
des 4 en fait on ouvre tout juste pour
que toutes les pièces blanches ou voilà
là on a fait des quatre pour libérer le
fou donc faut 3 bien sûr dame prend des
possibles de me prendre
il ya le clouage donc la dame s'en va
est fou provincial et et voilà il est
blanc espère pouvoir jouer un couple
cavalier
qui arrive déloger adam ii f 6 et mater
le long des colonnes f
toutes les pièces qui joue trois kényans
n'ont absolument rien développé
donc si vous voulez jouer ce dantec g5
et noir tout cas faut bien être au
courant de comment répondre à ce jardin
très agressive bon soit-il dans la
partie sur gk très bon fait qu'il
veuille ou cinq donc les morts va leur
idée sur les gardes ont résisté de
libérer la dame est fière d'un match 4
échecs
du coup les blancs se retrouve des
rockets est effondrée fin alors là
dessus la barre données continue de
manière hyper agressive et c'est pas
mauvais d'ailleurs différé 3 alors on
verra revenir dessus mais bien sûr ce
serait vraiment possible de jouer par un
bouquet vih 6 qui étaient ensuite joué
par par d'autres joueurs avec simplement
donc l'idée de défendre le pays accepte
qui a été attaqué donc les blancs tu
pourrais répliqué par des 4 prenant le
centre d'ici sont chasse le cavalier de
5 qui s'en va et maintenant pourquoi pas
f3 puisque le pion été attaqué et on va
être chercher un peu à fait bien le roi
blanc voilà donc une des parties
commentées joue là-dessus banque j'ai
trois dames f6 à noter que ça s'arrête
pas à grand chose de cet échec selon roy
120 01
et puis la dame est plutôt en fermer ici
en jeu 3 puisque à prêter aux livres 4
les
les juste attrapé quoi donc c'est pas un
coup très utile mais plutôt à daniel si
c'est mieux et par emprunt taxe des
quatre dont claude mader foule 3 une peu
comme kelly c 6
voilà c'est j'ai sûrement même une
position de meilleur pour les noirs quoi
mais là bordeaux n'est lui a joué le
coup et f3 alors avec les blancs il est
allé prendre prendre à droite avec le
cavalier alors assez logique puisque on
enferme la tour et on va gagner du
matériel on peut quand même se demander
ce qui se passait sur fion 23 je pense
qu'avec les noirs il voulait simplement
se développer avec cavalli m6 et ouvrir
la position du roi blanc le plus
possible
voilà preston des positions assez
sauvage mais laurent blanc peut être en
danger est aussi l'autre option pour les
blancs c'était de faire [ __ ] à 9,7
mais la vraisemblance simplement roi
russe est donc bon bah le roi est
bizarre mais le roi blanc aussi donc
c'est vrai si les pressions assez
sauvage dans une enseigne en miroir et
il aurait pu s'en suivre quelque chose
comme ça je penserai marc prenait
davantage ce qu'ils avaient en d3 pas
très bien placé si on n'a pas réussi à
jouer des quatre avant donc le fou c'est
un an ferme et dur à développer et de
support de nos offres un truc comme kyle
c6 et pourquoi pas fou j'ai s'être
toujours en fuite et s'en prendre aux
blancs impression prend le projet de
voie lactée les différentes options
blanche mais qu'elle est prête cette
raisonnable cas ici si ça a été jouée
ici il y avait un coût assez sympa qui
était bien citer by cinq dessins car
l'idée c'est de d'attaquer le fou mais
sur ce qu'ils font pire on va simplement
prendre cette donc ça c'est pas bon s'il
y avait des princes suite on va
récupérer le fond ces quatre et ceux qui
allaient ensuite enfermé donc on va le
prendre tôt ou tard comme ça et on aura
deux pièces pour la tour ce qui est très
bien pour les noirs donc
vraisemblablement à coups comme cube et
3 serait
ce serait plus logique et maintenant qui
allie m6 et guidée de ce b 5 puisque mon
qu'alexis ça fait de jouer sans insérer
des cinq poules et 3 c'est pas me sens
un peu comme les c3 qui est des
fonctions on pourrait avoir l'idée de
faire x 6 avec b 4 qui arrive et on a
ouvert cette diagonale pour attaquer le
roi ça c'était assez subtil comme idée
j'aimais bien et si les blancs prenaient
la tourache vite là en fait ils se font
directement attaqués et même si trop
grave pour sa précaire il prend le cas
très bon menace la mef de maths
disons que les blancs tu as ta main pour
pour défendre les prises en vue de
rapprocher deux donc pour l'instant le
blanc d'oeuf en demeure dames et damages
3 une seule case ici flou c5 et laurent
blanc ce matin c'est peut être ça aurait
pu être très violent cette idée de v5 et
c'était pas mal bon il a des qualités si
ce qui est pas mauvais non plus alors
dessus les blancs ont joué des quatre
bons joueurs donc ans il est blanc
prenait la balle à tour la leur arrivée
le même genre de mésaventure qu'on a vu
dans la variante précédente avec un
franc j'ai deux rangées de damages 3 par
exemple le redis ici
le cavaly vient vers m6 on veut prendre
ça il ya le foot a avancé 5 et le roi
blanc est vraiment trop esseulé et
et ça se passe très très mal pour les
blancs voilà donc ça il vaut mieux pas
faire des quatre donc c'était plutôt
bien joué
fu g7 on se développe en masse l'option
des quatre c3 mais là dessus sûrement
une faute
bon eh non je qualifie donc il continue
dans le même ordre d'idées qu'on a vus
mais ça a pas très bien marché même si
même si après ça demande un jeu très
précis la part des blancs après analyse
ici à une suite très joli mais
manquaient pas facilement c'était
cavaliers à 5 donc un peu le genre b5
tout à l'heure on veut s'en prendre au
fouet le dévier de cette diagonale et
bon bah il peut rester quelque part sur
la diagonale en dessin voulait pas
attaquer cavalli et 6 et qu'elle prend
la fuite
là les blancs prennent une tour donc ils
vont moins avoir une qualité plus mais
là dessus la le coup fantastique trouver
plus tard avec l'ars et b6 et ses
invités dont on parlait tout à l'heure
le flou y avait 1 6 et on veut s'en
prendre au roi blanc le problème
aujourd'hui c'est que fois c'est le
menace parce que sur gyan frappe de mata
est par exemple sur un coup comme damien
pour défendre alors on peut faire x 6 on
va dire c4 il faut bien bloquer les
chatons sur ces 4 on peut faire dame
prend 1
on reprend l'un qu'elle prend des cinq
combats pour reprendre et qu'elle est
pensée 4 est en fait les noirs on se
retrouve avec une qualité de moi voilà
je vous montre une possible voilà ici
mais des pièces active et on a déjà un
pion pour la qualité et son pion est
très faible
sûrement 2 par exemple 3f de on fait
quand le rock il ya des cinq qui peut
sauter
par différents moyens il y avait deux
qui est déjà attaqué par deux cavaliers
fou donc l'énorme recevoir deux pions
pour la qualité et ils se retrouvent
mieux bon après s'était pas franchement
évident de trouver cette idée donc l air
5 sur mon site envisagé mais il s'y
trouve b6 pas facile voilà faut avoir vu
peut-être des parties de ce steve avoir
remarqué la faiblesse de cette diagonale
pour sa moto cerveau parce que laisser
la tourache 8 comme ça c'est pas simple
mais bon là on voit bien que le prêt
soit 6 les blancs sont foutus mais il
faut juste arriver à l'envisager mais
bon toujours est-il dans la partie
l'affectif 6 bon bah il a pris la
tourache vite et donc son idée c'était
de continuer attaques par des 5 comprend
et cavaliers ou 4 donc on menace d'un
mec de maths les blancs font dames 1
est ce qu'il est prévu s'est adjugé 3
donc qui évite les changes des dames et
de deux ça ouvre le feu s'est vite on va
menacer des pions pranger de et réglant
h3 voilà et d'ailleurs c'est la menace
pas aussi les blancs ne font absolument
rien ici donc je vais jouer un coup
idiot juste pour montrer
l'idée des noirs ce serait donc de
prendre sur reprend on envoie le fond h3
le roi n'a que la caisse g1 est là un
joli coup vous pouvez mettre sur pause
pour chercher voilà si vous les faits il
veut trouver bravo à vous c'est kelly
prend des quatre et c'est foutu pour les
blancs parce que il va on arrive on
arrive pour pour mater on menace
cavaliers f3 ici donc voilà et si l'on
prend feu prend bon mais ya que flo
trois à jouer et on va prendre h2k la
dame qui ont l'air et il ya le roi même
qui va se faire mater par exemple sur
h2o on peut faire foule 5
c'est quand laurent revient en vient à
ce moment là on prend la dame et c'est
ça va être maintenant donc jolie
variante on voit la menace revient sur
les plantes sont pauvres deux à trois
qui est ridicule mais c'était juste pour
illustrer montrer la menace est ici
fallait trouver le le un très bon coup
de défense mais part introuvable
c'était qui a validé deux en fait
pourquoi parce que dans ce genre de
variantes
qu'on a vu avec flash 3g un epr en d4
le cavalier en d2 il est bien placé
parce qu'ils évitent le cavalier 3 donc
les blancs en un coup pour souffler donc
ça peut être pour prendre en g3 ça peut
être même je pense pour jouer avec mon
projet trans et bien ouais tu comprends
g3 c'est ça je vais vous dire une bêtise
j'ai à vous dire même dame prend le 4
mai la douleur ce match là sa c5 tourer
d'études lesaffre est d'apprendre
qu'elle valait prend il ya cavaliers
froid et le roi blanc retrouvent en
boîte mais non qui a aidé deux très bien
est sorti en france j'ai deux donc voilà
qu'on a vu il y avait le pion range
étroit et du coup ici du racoleur
continuer simplement l'aleba les blancs
menace de prendre ce cas valises et
changer les dames et y avait passé
c'était gagné en fait après qu'il ait
deux pour le blanc mais il fallait
trouver ce coup qui défend des
infirmières et sur un couvent en kung fu
f5 pour défendre le cavalier ou quatre
cahiers pour un f3 et la démence ou pour
l'instant une porte plus il ya le
cavalier c6 qui attaquait et même si le
roi un peu dans les courants d'air ça va
on a comblé les trous et tout va bien
alors dans la partie
genre avec les blancs achever food et 3
donc il voulait seulement faire du dam
34 mais maintenant la tacc mars met en
place et il n'y a plus rien à faire donc
on va regarder ce parti puis on prend
j'ai 2 bras pranger deux fois je crois
en rage et 1 et ils nous jouent le même
tout à l'heure qu'avait dépend des cas
alors on a déjà compris on a déjà vu
tout à l'heure le match si on prend en
[ __ ] en faut trois j'en prends h2 on a
vu dans la vente précédente
c'est la même chose si les blancs font
fut promu quatre là ça va être pareil on
prend h 2 et comme la dame est attaqué
c'est même problème reprend 5 l'europe
sur la première dame prendre un math et
ce qui nous reste c'est toujours dans la
partie cède 1.4 pour échanger adam riess
prise mais la jolie match final avec les
lieux deux voilà une belle partie
d'attac
tout n'a pas été parfait mais on a vu
des jolies petites combines et voilà
puis ce schéma de match final c'est
sympa avec le pion le fouet le cavalier
ici et le roi donc hissé mater un peu
voilà coincé dans son coin
et voilà ça a montré un peu toutes ses
capacités de calcul et ce bon jeu de
tête qui avait la bourdonnais aller plus
qu'une sur la bord donna blanc passera à
autre chose
bon je retrouve une prochaine vidéo à
bientôt ciao ciao